besinler içerisinde son başlığımız
proteinler hücre ve dokuların
bütünlüğünü sağlamada görev alıyor
metabolik tepkimelerin gerçekleşmesinde
oksijen demir moleküllerinin
taşınmasında depolanmasında görev
alıyormuş hormon reseptör metabolik
süreçlerin düzenlenmesi hücrelerin
sinyal iletilmesinde rol alıyor antikor
olabiliyor ki savunma hocam Ne diyorsun
Bekle hücredeki hareket proteinleri kas
kasılmasında ve hücre içinde
moleküllerin taşınmasında görev alıyor
proteinler enerji kayna olarak
kullanılabiliyor ben şöyle özetleyeyim
mi sana proteinler kan gazlarını taşır
adı hemoglobin olur protein savunma
yapar adı antikor olur protein yapıya
katılır derinin saçın tırnağın adı
keratin olur protein kaslarda oksijen
depolar adı miyoglobin olur protein
dna'yı Sarar adı Histon olur kasların
kasılmasını sağlar aktin miyozin olur E
bir de aminoasitler enerji vere gibi
gibi gibi yüzlerce binlerce görevi var
proteinlerin O yüzden proteinler öyle
kafamıza göre yıktığımız Hadi yıkalım
enerjisini alalım dediğimiz moleküller
değildir bir de şunu unutmayın insanda
protein
depolanmaz Biz ne depoluyor nötral yağ
değil mi dün öğrendik nötral yağ
depoluyor protein depolamıyor
proteinleri yapıya katıyoruz hocam
hormon olabiliyor işte insülin Glukagon
gibi hormonlar mesela protein yapılı
hücre içerisinde sinyal Taşıyan Ya da
hücre zarında hücreye geçtiğimiz zaman
öğreneceksiniz glikoprotein gibi
reseptör olan bir şeyleri tanımamıza
yardımcı olan maddeler de olabiliyor
nedir proteinlerin yapı taşı aminoasit
aminoasitlere baktığınız zaman bir Alfa
karbon Merkez karbon bir Radikal Grup
değişken aminoasitlerin birbirinden
farklı olmasını sağlayan Grup bir
hidrojen grubu karboksil grubu ve amino
grubu var ya Yani bütün amino asitlerde
aslında şu kısım ortak Ama bu kısım
değişken Mesela bu kısım sadece
hidrojene aminoasit adı glisin Metil
grubu İsa alanin ch2 ch2 S3 metiyonin
ch2 S sülfidril grubu varsa sistein gibi
bu böyle sabaha kadar sürer hocam Zamanı
gelince aminoasitleri de bu şekilde
öğreneceksiniz daha çok erken Peki hocam
aminoasitlerin yan yana dizilmesi aynı
glikozların yan yana dizilmesi gibi
rastgele mi olu yani Glukoz Glikoz
glikoz şeklinde dizilme ile glikojen
nişasta gibi şeyler sentezli Canlar Peki
aminoasitte de mi öyle oluyor Hani
kafasına göre hücre alıp aminoasitleri
yan yana mı diziyor Hayır aminoasitler
dna'dan gelen şifreye göre yan yana
dizilir bunu protein sentezinde
öğreneceksiniz Yani bir kod olacak ve bu
kod bize aminoasitleri hangi sıraya göre
dizmem gerektiğini söyleyecek işte Bizim
birbirimizden de farklı olmamızı
sağlayan temel şeylerden bir tanesi bu
Çünkü tek yumurta ikizleri hariç
herkesin DNA'sı farklı baktığımız zaman
aminoasitler yan yana geliyorlar Ve
tabii ki bu bir Dehidrasyon tepkimesi
Dehidrasyon su atmak bakın bağ kadar su
açığa çıkıyor çıkmış sınav sorusudur
Eğer siz şu şekilde amino asitleri
yazarsanız yan yana şuraya Radikal Grup
şuraya amino grubu buraya hidrojen hadi
buraya da bir tane h2n cooh
hidrojen ve R yazalım 2 amino asit bu
şekilde yan yana gelecek 1 aminoasitin
karboksili ile ik aminoasitin amino
grubu arasında peptit bağı kurulacak ve
İşte o su nasıl çıkacaktı buradaki
hidroksil buradaki hidrojenler bir
tanesi karboksil hidroksil kaybetti
amino grubu hidrojeni kaybetti ve bu
şekilde oluşan bağın adı peptit bağı
oldu bir tane su çıktı arkadaşlar bakın
ik tane Amin yan yana geldiğinde biz bu
yapıya dipeptit diyoruz Tamam iki
aminoasit yan yana gelmesi dipeptit 3
tane aminoasit yan yana geldiğinde de
adı tripeptit olur burada dipeptit ik
peptit bağ demek değil 2 aminoasit demek
tripeptit 3 peptit bağ değil 3 aminoasit
demek Buna da dikkat edelim Mesela bir
dipeptit sentezlendiği kaç su çıkar bir
tane su çıkar bak Bir tane bağ var Çünkü
bu şekilde de testlerde matematiksel
sorularla karşılaşıyorsunuz Şimdi burada
ünlem attığım çok kıymetli bir bilgi var
yine ÖSYM'nin sormayı sevdiği bir soru
proteinler sentezlendiği anda işlevsel
değildir yani siz bir protein
sentezlediği işte Nasıl olabilir hocam O
birazdan bir siyah sayfada açarım sizin
için bu bir DNA molekülü işte dna'dan
mrna denilen mesajcı RNA sentezlenir
sonra ribozoma gidiyor ribozomda bir
protein sentezi hop protein sentezlenir
şimdi bu protein in sentezlendiği ilk
hale Primer protein Primer Yapı diyoruz
ve ne demiş kitabımız bu hiçbir işe
yaramaz yani işlevsel değildir bakın
yeni sentezlenen polipeptit işlevsel
değildir ne olması lazım katlanması
lazım hocam işlevsel olmaları için ü
boyutlu Yapı kazanması lazım Bazen de
birden fazla peptit yan yana gelmesi
lazım Mesela bizim hemoglobin imiz yani
kanımıza kırmızı rengini veren oksijen
taşınmasını sağlayan protein 4 tane
zincirden oluşur 2 Alfa 2 Beta Hatta
duyarsınız Alfa Talasemi Beta Talasemi
Hani bunlar anemi türleridir İşte o Alfa
ve Beta kelimeleri buradan gelir Çünkü
hemoglobinde 4 tane zincir vardır
yapılarında demir var bu iki
zincirin ikisi Alfa ikisi badır
Arkadaşlar bu zincirlerde işte problem
olduğunda ona göre hastalık isim alıyor
Alfa talesemi Beta talesemi gibi Peki o
zam o zaman buradan yola çıkarak
işlevsel hale gelmesi için proteinin ne
olması gerekiyormuş hocam ya katlanması
gerekiyor ya da katlanma ile beraber
birden fazla da protein zincirin bir
araya gelmesi gerekiyormuş buraya
meraklısı için şaperonlar diye bir
kelime koydum moleküler biyolojinin yapı
taşıdır şaperon proteinler meraklısı
araştırabilir proteinlerin üç boyutlu
yapısı onların fonksiyonel hale
gelmesini sağlıyormuş çok güzel Bravo
ama bazen bazı durumlarda sıcaklık
değişimleri pH değişimleri ortamın iyon
şiddeti tuz konsantrasyonu değiştiği
zaman proteinin üç boyutlu yapısı
bozulabiliyor İşte biz buna denatürasyon
diyoruz D latincede olumsuzluk atmak
Natur doğal
denatürasyon doğal halinin bozulması
demek D Nature denatürasyon doğal hali
bozuluyor proteinlerin katlanması
değişiyor yani burada dikkat etmemiz
gereken şey çıkmış ÖSYM sorusu da çok
tatlı bir şey sormuştu demişti ki
denatürasyonda hangi bağ etkilenmez
denatürasyonda peptit bağa etkilenmez
Yani bir proteinin üç boyutlu yapısı
bozulduğu zaman onun aminoasit dizilişi
falan değişmiyor
değişseydi dünyada renatürasyon diye bir
kelime zaten Olmazdı çünkü bazen üç
boyutlu yapısı değişen proteinler o
bozulmaya neden olan faktör ortadan
kalktığı zaman tekrar eski haline
gelebiliyor bazen her zaman değil yani
siz bir yumurtayı kızarttığınız zaman o
denatüre oldu Onu renature hale
getiremezsin Tamam ama mesela Saçınız
kıvırcıktır girersiniz banyoya
yıkarsınız dümdüz çıkarsınız bak bir
denatürasyon oldu Şu anda Çünkü saç
protein keratin proteinler sonra
kurumaya başladığında Saçınız tekrar ne
olacak eski haline gelecek işte
denatürasyonda renatürasyon geldi
buradaki olay de şu Aslında bazı
aminoasitler arasında disülfit köprüleri
kurulur arkadaşlar bakın şurada Sülfür
içeren değişken gruplar ifadesi Bu bir
kalsın ekranı kararttığı zaman buna
gireceğim tamam mı hocam süt
ısıtıldığında içinde bulunan proteinler
denatüre olur soğutulduğunda ü boyutlu
Yapı geri kazanılabilir bazı durumlarda
Ama bu olmayabilir dedik yumurtayı
kızarttım o gitti artık tamam Ha üç
boyutlu yapının değişmesi besin
değerinin kaybolması anlamına gelmez
proteinin işlev yapamayacağı anlamına
gelir Çünkü eğer besin değeri kayb
olsaydı o zaman biz eti pişirmez
yumurtayı kızartması değil mi çiğ çiğ
yerdik Bu da yine testlerde karşınıza
çıkan cümlelerden bazıları olacak işte
denatüre renature Muhabbet Evet
enzimlere tabii ki Girmiyorum enzimler
bambaşka bir konu şimdi hocam bir
gözlerimizi dinlendir şöyle bir arkanıza
yaslanın arkadaşlar proteinler konusu
önemli hocam Tabii ki her konu önemli
ama buradan çok fazla soru var protein
sentezine de hazırlık olsun karbon
hidrojen oksijen azot kesin var
bazılarında fosfor kükürt vesaire de
olabiliyor Sülfür içeren amino asidi
çizeceğim zaman Tabi ki bunları böyle
çizmeyi ezberlemeyin Ben size bir
şeylerin mantığını anlatmaya çalışıyorum
hani ezberi bilmek zorunda değilsiniz
Ama biyokimya moleküler biyolojik
uğraşırsanız Tabii ki bunları
öğreneceksiniz ch2 sh şöyle yapalım bir
tane daha ch2 sh amino asit çizelim
mantık arkadaşlar Ben size mantığını
öğretmeye çalışıyorum şimdi bu iki tane
amino asit Tabii ki peptit bağı ile yan
yana gelecek Yani karboksil şu şekilde
hidroksil
kaybettiğini şöyle olsun H2 E'nin de
hidrojen kaybettiğini düşünüyorum ve
şurada bakın bir peptit bağı
oluşturuyorum bu peptit bağı burada bir
sıkıntı yok ama bir de bu ch2 sh ch2 sh
var ya sülfidril grupları bunu organik
kimy öğreneceksiniz sülfidril grubundaki
hidrojenler şu şekilde arkadaşlar
kaybolursa şurada kükürt arasında da Bağ
kurulur işte proteinin katlanmasını
sağlayan bağlardan bir tanesi kükürt
kükürt yani disülfit köprüleri bunlardır
Tabii arada hidrojen hidrojen bağları da
oluşuyor Eğer siz bir proteini mesela
buralarda bir sürü aminoasit olsun bir
proteini denatüre etmek için şunu
kopartır sınız
peptit bağını değil peptit bağı sağlam
Kalır O yüzden tekrar edelim
denatürasyonda
peptit bağına zarar
gelmez amino asit dizilişi
değişmez Dolayısıyla amino asit sayısı
vesaire korunur ve bu bağın kopmasına
neden olan şey ortadan kalktığında
tekrar eski haline gelebilir
işte biz de buna
renatürasyon renature yani doğal halini
tekrar kazanması diyoruz renatürasyon
renatürasyon muhabbetimiz bu her
denatürasyonda sonra renatürasyon olmak
zorunda değil denatürasyonda peptit bağı
korunur aminoasit sırası değişmez
katlanma bozulur fonksiyonel Yapı
kaybolur Peki hocam Ne dedin sen bize
hemoglobin olabilir oksijen taşınması
miyoglobin olabilir kaslarda oksijen
depolanması aktin miyozin proteinleri
kas kasılması Histon proteinler dna'yı
sararak onu böyle koruması keratin saç
tırnak deri yapımına katılması antikor
savunma proteini Bağışıklık sisteminin
bir elemanı olması hücre iskelet
elemanları bunu hücrede öğreteceğim size
mikrotübül mikrofilament ara filamentler
Hücrenin şeklinin korunması organellerin
sabitlenmesi çekirdeğin sabitlenmesi
gibi görevler görecekler yani
Dolayısıyla hocam protein inler Deniz
Derya enzim konusu olacak katalizör
hormon konusu olacak düzenleyici Bunlar
bakın çok ama çok kıymetli protein
Elbette ki yapısal dır zorunlu hallerde
aminoasitler enerji kaynağı olabilir
arkadaşlar tamam mı kaynağı Olabilir ama
proteinleri depolamıyor ben söylediğim
için Arkadaşlar bu cümleleri biraz böyle
hızlı yazıyorum yazı karakterime
takılmayın tamam mı Sonuçta bu bir
tekrar az önce söylediğim şeyleri tekrar
ediyorum Bir protein sentezlendiği
sırada Primer haldedir ve bu protein
işlevsel değildir işlevsel olabilmesi
için katlanması gerekir katlanma
bozulduğu zaman biz buna denatürasyon
dedik az önce proteinlerin yapıtaşları
amino asitlerdir aminoasitlere
baktığımız zaman karboksil grubu asidik
özellik amino grubu bazik özellik
gösteriyor O yüzden hocam Aslında nedir
amfoter özellik gösterir ve unutmayın
amino asit kelimesinin içerisinde asit
kelimesi var Ancak bütün aminoasitler
asidik değildir bazıları bazik bazıları
nötür bazıları asidiktir ilk bulunanlar
asidik olduğu için öyle sanılmış Mesela
yine meraklısı için lizin arjinin
histidin baziktir glutamik asit aspart
asit asidiktir glisin nötrdür gibi 20
çeşit amino asidim var ve yetişkin bir
insanda Mesela ben de çocuklarda değil
ben de 12 tanesini
sentezler 8'ini dışarıdan
alırım işte Bu dışarıdan aldıklarımı
arkadaşlar temel yani esansiyel
aminoasit denir aynı esansiyel yağ asidi
gibi bunları dışarıdan almak zorundayım
kendim
üretememe ne diyormuşum temel amino asit
diyormuşum Evet proteinler bu kadar
arkadaşlar okul kitabımızda gördüğünüz
gibi bir sayfa vesaire Umarım
anlaşılmıştır hepinize kolay gelsin